but mr speaker i don't think the public
will be hoodwinked the families who will
be unable to visit
they laugh mr speaker but the families
will be unable to visit their relations
music fans hoping to go to glastonbury
the students unable to get to their
exams their gcses and their a levels
businesses just beginning to recover
from covet and people who will miss out
people who will miss out on their
medical treatment because of these
strikes that is what they are supporting
mr speaker they know that this week's
rail strikes created by the unions
organized by the unions is the full
responsibility of the unions too
of course
we're ordering our utmost to get the
unions in the rail industry to agree a
way forward and call off the strikes
because in discussions like this it's
always the employer and the unions who
need to get together and negotiate and
in the case in this case that's the
train operating companies it's network
rail and it's their union
representatives mr speaker we are not
the employer and we are not undermined
the process as well
and i hear i hear the calls i hear the
calls of the labour leadership opposite
saying we should somehow get involved
and perhaps invite the unions for beer
and sandwiches to discuss the situation
well mr speaker we all know the leader
of the opposition thinks a beer and
curry is a work meeting but we will be
leaving this to the employers who are
the right people to negotiate with the
unions indeed indeed the unions are in
daily talks with the employers
or at least they were until they walked
out an hour ago to go and hold a press
conference saying that the strikes would
be on and mr speaker
we're doing everything we can despite
these strikes to minimize the disruption
throughout the entire network
we're working with the civil contingency
sectaria
the government's emergency planning team
to keep critical supply chains open
wherever possible operators will keep as
many passenger trains as possible
running though of course with as much
disruption to the timetable and that is
going to be very difficult on strike
days and it's estimated that around 20
percent of planned services will operate
focused on key workers main population
centers and critical freight routes